foreign
[Music]
good morning
welcome to this first day of cloud next
23 and this first session post the
keynote super excited to have so many of
you in the audience to talk about
identity and access management this is
going to be a power packed 45 minutes
and I'm gonna give you a full Whirlwind
tour of everything that Google cloud has
for you in terms of identity and access
management
let's quickly get started as folks are
walking in there are some seats here but
please do settle in really quick let's
start off by talking about what we are
going to cover over the next 45 minutes
I'm going to start off by giving you a
sense of some of the trends that we are
watching as Google now these Trends are
based on what customers tell us what
analysts tell us what's generally
happening with the industry but I'm
going to share a few that are of
particular interest to Google I'm going
to talk about how that translates into
the full stack identity and access
management that we have on Google Cloud
we're then going to start go deeper and
talk about identity policy policy
intelligence and some emerging scenarios
in the space of identity and access
management
I also have some demos towards the end
and I promise to leave some time for Q a
but if we run over my team and I we are
sitting in the first row we are happy to
meet you outside the session over a
favorite beverage and we can continue
the conversation
with that let's quickly get started with
introductions so what we're going to do
is we're going to go around the room and
we're going to come up with two truths
and a lie
no
too much pressure to come up with a lie
all right so let's keep it simple let me
quickly introduce you to myself my name
is Abhishek I'm a director of product at
Google my team and I build the identity
and access management capabilities on
Google Cloud
so let's start off by some key identity
and access management trends that we
believe all of us should be paying
attention to
this one
now customers routinely tell us that it
is becoming very very difficult to think
about their Cloud deployments as secure
by default now the good news is with the
advancements in infrastructures code
policy s code generative AI it's
starting to become very real to think
about self-securing and as I like to
think about them as self-healing Cloud
deployments so the notion of secure by
default in the cloud is an important
area and you'll see us invest more in
that particular domain
the next one is around just the proper
identity and access management space
itself like a lot of people talk about
how identity systems are Legacy access
management capabilities are Legacy well
the reality is in the cloud context
building Cloud first identity and access
management privilege access management
account takeover prevention fine grain
Access Control just-in-time access these
are in many ways emerging capabilities
and vendors are starting to build more
and more cloud-first Cloud native
Technologies in this area now the way I
like to think about them is these are
not just point solutions they need to be
a set of woven tools that work across
your identity and access management
capabilities both from uh admin time
capability point of view and a runtime
capability point of view so in one of
the subsequent sections I'll go through
how I like to think about the Spectrum
or the Continuum of access management
capabilities but the good news is this
is an emerging space so all of us is I
am practitioners it's a great space to
be in
the next one is around the just the pure
notion of entitlements now there is data
that's available that across all of the
clouds
95 principles use less than three
percent of the permissions that they
have been granted so all of us in this
room are sitting with 97 entitlements on
an average that we do not use now that's
a problem it's a problem because we
could all become accidental or
intentional malicious insiders or or our
accounts might get taken over and it may
cause an identity breach so the notion
of entitlement management is becoming
super important from a I am point of
view
the fourth one is
one is a Eventing account takeovers both
for human and machine identities and
what that really means is investments in
login fraud detection Step Up
authentication and other strategies that
can both solve the user experience
during the during the authenticated
session but also prevent any kind of
account takeovers now this is an
interesting data from Microsoft that
over 78 of the Azure ad client base does
not have MFA turned on so even though we
are investing in more capabilities in
this area even basic things like MFA
aren't turned on and if you think about
how popularly Azure ID gets used I think
that's a huge problem so we need to get
to broader MFA adoption and then finally
identity is the ultimate threat surface
but it can also be the ultimate control
surface and that's the direction that we
want to move the industry towards so
with that let's quickly start talking
about how does this start representing
at Google cloud and what we think about
as the full stack Cloud IM I'm going to
start off by talking about our mission
as a company we are on a path to enable
identity first AI ml powered and
policy-based security for your users for
your infra for your data and for your
applications so the three things to
focus on are identity first AI ml
powered and policy based so the
subsequent portion of my conversation
this session is going to focus on those
exact three areas
what that really translates into is a
full stack IM that can be represented
the way it's going to get built out on
the screen starting with the identity
platform so in terms of identity we have
a broad spectrum of capabilities
available for you in terms of cloud
identity Workforce identity Federation
workload identity Federation a very
robust certificate management platform
and also for your customer identity
management scenarios the gcip capability
so from Workforce workload and cim you
have end-to-end capabilities available
as part of the Google identity platform
now if you go a step about that that's
where access management starts coming
into the play and our view of access
management is an end-to-end policy-based
access control system and notice I talk
about both admin time authorization and
runtime authorization so capabilities
like identity governance things that you
do when a new employee joins or on an
occasional basis for an audit that's an
admin time capability versus giving
somebody privileged access approvals at
runtime that's a runtime authorization
capability but notice the spectrum of
runtime authorization capabilities is
now starting to more prominently feature
things like fine grain access control or
account takeover prevention or things
like MPA and MFA
and then finally if you have a robust
identity and access management stack you
can then start thinking about
differentiated scenarios that IM lights
up for your applications and for your
deployments scenarios like itdr identity
threat detection and response but also
for your application the notion of
application security or fraud prevention
all of these capabilities require IIM to
be robust and to work well with each
other so I see a lot of you have cameras
in your in the air taking a photograph
this is perhaps the most important slide
in my conversation today so I'd urge you
to take a photograph but this is what
we're going to talk about over the next
few sections
so with that let's start going deeper
all right all right
fantastic
let's start talking about identity so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
talk about two aspects of identity I'm
going to talk about human identities or
Workforce identity Federation and I'm
going to talk about machine identities
or workload identity and Federation and
if I keep mixing up Workforce workload I
want you all to be in mind Mill with me
and exactly get what I mean but I'm
going to try not to mess up those two
things
so when it comes to Workforce
authentication scenarios this is what we
hear from customers as yourself
now many customers who use gcp today
already use cloud identity Cloud
identity offers the capability of
synchronizing your existing identity
provider so your users and your groups
get synchronized over to Google cloud
and then you can start managing your
Google cloud services now the feedback
that customers have given us over the
years is
the first one you know customers have
extended Workforce or partners that they
do not want to onboard to their primary
identity provider and occasionally they
have a secondary IDP for them and they
want to just for those specific users
onboard that secondary identity provider
without having to synchronize it without
having to go through all of that
investment so that's an extended
Workforce scenario scenario that we
typically didn't have until now and then
the second one is I'm a net new Google
Cloud user can I just start by not
having to synchronize my IDP so I use
OCTA or Azure ad and I just want to get
started with Google not having to worry
about investing and synchronizing or any
compliance that comes with it so those
two scenarios now the good news is we've
now built an enabled workload identity
Federation Workforce identity Federation
which allows you to achieve exactly that
so you could be a pure play Google Cloud
customer today that's using Cloud
identity which synchronizes your users
and your groups from your IDP over to
Google in a sense making them Cloud
identities
or you can use the workforce identity
Federation feature in addition to Cloud
identity and what that allows you to do
is onboard a secondary IDP without
having to synchronize it but the good
news is you could start by choosing just
to be a Workforce identity Federation
customer meaning bring your ad bring
your octa no need to synchronize
anything no need to worry about
compliance or any additional Investments
you can get started with Google cloud in
a matter of a few minutes so in one of
my demos I'm going to actually show you
how this new capability of Workforce
identity Federation actually works in a
sense unlocking those two scenarios a
new customer onboarding without having
to synchronize or existing customer
getting to onboard an extended Workforce
with Google Cloud
now the workforce identity identity
Federation feature is designed to
leverage your existing identity
Investments you simply have your
identity provider where your users and
your groups and their claims are based
our tokenization service takes care of
all of the authentication and the
pass-through in a sense enabling access
to Google Cloud apis the console and SDK
seamless experience and we'll see that
in the demo
so in terms of announcements at next are
Workforce identity Federation capability
now supports 76 Google cloud services
including important services like GCE
and that coverage is dramatically going
to expand over the next few months and
by the end of the year you should have
comprehensive coverage across all of gcp
services and then just in terms of new
features a whole bunch of features on
the screen the one that I want to
particularly call out is that the
support for authorization code flow when
you're using openid connect in terms of
setting up that Federation
all right now let's move on and talk
about workload authentication scenarios
now just as Workforce authentication has
a few scenarios machine authentication
also can have two prominent scenarios
you may have a scenario where you want
to authenticate your workloads to Google
Cloud apis so your workloads that are
running on GCE on gke cloud run
serverless or workloads that are running
on-prem or on AWS or Azure you may want
to authenticate them with Google Cloud
apis
or you may have a scenario when you want
to authenticate your workloads with
other workloads so let's say you have a
workload running on gke and you want to
authenticate that workload with a
workload that's on-prem using spiffy all
of these scenarios are already covered
by the Google Cloud workload identity
capabilities for workload authentication
so for example you could be on gke and
to authenticate with Google Cloud apis
you could use gke workload identity or
you could be on AWS Azure or on-prem and
you can use workload identity Federation
to authenticate with Google Cloud apis
now in terms of coverage for workload
authentication scenarios from service
accounts to gke workload identity to
workload identity Federation and mesh
identity we believe we have end-to-end
capabilities that are robust work for a
variety of scenarios the customer was
telling me about a scenario where they
have a hybrid deployment these are the
options that would work for them today
but we believe that Google has an
opportunity to keep innovating in this
area so what you're going to see us is
build a unified identity across all
environments which has strong life cycle
management security and industry-based
nomenclature so we're going to
standardize on spiffy so over time what
you're going to see is our entire
managed workload identity platform and
the notion of a workload identity pool
will become unified across all types of
scenarios so if you're authenticating
with Google cloud services for workloads
running on Google cloud or workloads
running on non-google cloud on-prem or
in other clouds you'll be able to use a
consistent workload identity City Pool
backed by a certificate Authority
service to carry out those scenarios now
that's not a super Future Vision in fact
this is happening now so by the end of
this year you'll see a streamline
multiple identity Types on Google Cloud
we'll start off by streamlining the gke
and Google Cloud workload identity pools
some announcements on the screen
available in terms of the workload
authentication area the one that I'd
call for you to pay attention to is the
ability for Now setting service count
key expiration this is an important
important feature it allows you to have
better posture and better security
related to your workload authentication
with service accounts
all right so that's a you know high
level view of everything that we're
doing in identity later today we have a
dedicated session on identity where my
team's gonna bring Goldman Sachs on the
stage and take the theory into the
actual practical on how a customer
implements some of these capabilities
and I strongly encourage you to attend
that towards the end I'll have session
codes that will give you the
understanding of what those sessions are
so with identity
out of the way let's talk about
policy-based access control and as I
mentioned we think about this as admin
time and runtime capabilities for access
management all using a unified policy
platform now when it comes to
policy-based controls we have three
categories of controls controls that
help you with resource access
controls that help help you with
resource configuration and controls that
help you with resource boundary so the
example of a resource Access Control
would be a resource-centric policy which
helps determine what kind of permission
does a principal have against a resource
so an example of that would be does
Abhishek have the ability to create a
virtual machine in a project that's a
resource-centric policy or a resource
access control the second class of
controls is around resource
configurations this is organization
policies and customer organization
policies and what that really tells
talks about is what can kind of
configurations are allowed or denied so
that they can be enforced right when the
resource is being created in a sense
helping you to get towards secure by
default so for example can I create a
bucket with Public Access if I have an
organization policy that prohibits that
a bucket with such access would never be
able to get created so that's resource
configuration and then there's a third
class of emerging controls that we now
have which ensure that you can set guard
rails around which organizations can
your resources actually deal with now
that's a very important control because
it can help you in terms of data
exfiltration and Insider risk scenarios
so you can set organization restrictions
to say my admin cannot even interact
with an organization that's not the
organization that I have configured for
them so those are controls that are set
at the resource boundary in a sense
between resource access resource config
and resource boundary you get defense in
depth across your deploy moment
so let's start talking about Google
Cloud IM I'm going to talk about the six
principles that went into when we built
Google Cloud IM starting with the first
one which is centered around Simplicity
we have a universal notion of resource
hierarchy in Google which is cloud
resource manager and a universal
identity and access management
experience that works across all of the
gcp services now that's important
because we can all agree identity and
access management tends to be a complex
area but it's also an area that you need
to really get through quicker so that
you can start dealing with deploying
infrastructure and applications and
managing your workloads in the cloud so
Simplicity goes a long way to make it
easy for customers to adopt the Google
Cloud platform the second one is around
make identity easy so everything that I
spoke about in terms of Workforce
identity Federation the options that you
now have use cloud Identity or bring
your own identity with Workforce
identity Federation don't have to
synchronize them or use a combination of
both that makes identity easy so we are
no longer mandating an approach that
should be used you can decide what
approach works best for you and get to
the more important aspects of your Cloud
deployment
the third one is the ability to right
size roles now this is almost intuitive
but oftentimes not followed mapping job
functions to the correct roles so that
users have exactly the permissions that
they need to perform their jobs but the
reality is all of us have 97
entitlements that we don't use and
that's where access control natively
from the platform is super important so
we have capabilities like I am role
recommender which can periodically tell
you permissions that you never use but
you're still holding on to them
the next one is around the ability to
set context to make an authentication
decision context such as what's the
security status of my device what's the
IP address that I'm coming from what's
the date and the time what's the
location these are important attributes
that can help make a strong decision
around the reputation of the session
itself
and then finally a comprehensive audit
trail that allows you to have a deep
understanding of when were permissions
granted what privileges were escalated
your ability to attest from a compliance
point of view so these are the six
principles around which the Google Cloud
identity and access management platform
was built now I know I spoke about admin
time and runtime so over the next two
slides I'm going to take you through a
very very important admin time
capability this is the third time I'm
going to say it in this session 95
percent of us have 97 permissions that
we do not use we need to start locking
those down because that's an identity
threat service surface waiting to be
compromised so at Google we have an AI
ml powered capability called IM role
recommender that helps you do just that
and we had Ai and IM role recommender
even before it was cooler to say AI in
every sentence but the way I am role
recommender works is let's say you have
a set of permissions that have been
granted to you
over a period of time you tend to use
only few of those permissions so maybe
you're using half of those in theory the
administrator should be able to go in
and take away the rest of the
permissions now what customers tell us
is yes that makes sense I should take
away the permissions but I don't know
when the user may actually need those
permissions and when they do need the
permissions it can cause a lot of
trouble it can hamper productivity so
how do you take away the permissions
that the user will never need but still
leave behind permissions that they may
need even if they have not used and
that's where the AIML aspect of the IM
road recommender comes in we are able to
look at your usage in the past 90 days
at a user level but then also look at
data at a broader organization level to
make predictions on permissions that may
get used even if they were not used over
the last 90 days what that allows you to
do is right size permissions in the most
effective manner in a sense enabling
least privilege with least effort so
your recommendations are based on 90
days data we leverage Ai and ml to make
the right size recommendation we also
recommend roles that are going to be the
best roles for the particular role to be
fine-tuned to and the best part you
don't need any configuration or any
setup to use the IM role recommender so
take away number one from this session
is if you haven't looked at I am role
recommender in Google Cloud I'd
encourage you to check it out it's a
pretty cool feature it works by default
and it can really tell you stuff that
you don't need in there in terms of
permission across your across your user
base so that's admin time authorization
enabled with entitlement Management on
IM role recommender
now when it comes to runtime
authorization capabilities this is a
spectrum of capabilities now
unfortunately the way we've all
traditionally implemented these
capabilities is that we tend to
implement them in silos and we need to
start moving away from that all of the
identity and access management systems
need to talk to each other because when
an identity threat is in progress that
Telemetry that's unified across IM is
what can help you protect your IM
systems and your Cloud deployments so in
terms of just-in-time and privileged
access you may wonder if Google cloud
has privileged access management
natively we already do have capabilities
that can help you set up what kind of
roles need additional entitlements what
kind of users need additional
entitlements can there be a requester
can there be an approver over time what
you'll see us do is build that even more
natively into the platform right now
it's available as a capability that you
run on cloud run in your targeted
deployment you'll see this become a more
native platform capability in the coming
months or you can do something like a
time-based condition in an IM policy
which allows you to enable break glass
access for an administrator so let's say
somebody needs access at to troubleshoot
a production issue but if you use a
time-based condition that access can be
revoked within a few hours that way the
user is not sitting with permission that
they don't need after the production
issue is over
the other aspect is around multi-factor
authentication so if you're a cloud
identity user you have variety of
methods available for your second Factor
you can use backup codes you can use the
authenticator app you can use the Google
prompt and you can use security Keys as
we do at Google if you're on boarding
your third party identity provider using
the workforce identity Federation
feature we will honor the MFA setting in
that identity provider as well so if you
are one of those 22 Azure 80 users that
are using MFA we will honor the MFA but
the reality is that MFA adoption needs
to get better
the next one is around fine grain access
now the way I think about fine grain
access is you can think about access at
a resource hierarchy getting finer so
can somebody get access at an org level
at a folder level at a project level at
a resource level you can do that with IM
policy so I can go and get access
directly at a virtual machine or at a
project where that virtual machine is
based so that's fineness in terms of
resource hierarchy but there's also the
notion of fine grain access in terms of
data so am I allowed to query data that
is already classified as pii so with
capabilities available in bigquery and
spanner you can already do that today so
both in terms of resource and data you
have fine-grained access capabilities
available and then the final one is
account takeover prevention where you'll
see a lot more activity from us
currently in Cloud identity you can go
and configure the session length after
which a session is get it gets
re-authenticated by the system itself
what we are now working on is for select
send sensitive actions you'll be able to
configure policies which force a
reauthentication on the principle so
let's say somebody is trying to download
a service account key that's a sensitive
action and if a user is trying to carry
out that action even if they're
authenticated and there were no other
risk indicators because you have a
policy in place which says every time
somebody tries to download a service
account key force them to
re-authenticate so that there is no
cookie theft or account takeover risk
we'll be able to honor that intent so
across runtime authorization
capabilities I would strongly encourage
you to look at just in time privilege
access MFA fine grain access control and
finally the account takeover prevention
capabilities built into the gcp platform
all right so that's policy let's quickly
talk about policy intelligence and then
we'll talk about you know some of the
emerging scenarios in this space now
when it comes to policies somebody was
asking me yesterday when they looked at
this diagram they were like Abhishek
where does it start and where does it
end the reality is it starts only on day
one when you create your policies for
the first time it never ends because
that's how posture is you need to
constantly keep evolving and fine-tuning
your posture to make it more robust so
you can design your policies using our
recommender capabilities but over time
as you deploy them you need to be sure
that this deployment is not going to
break something this is another feedback
that we hear from customers that I know
I need to roll out this control but I'm
afraid literally that usage I'm afraid
to roll out the control because I don't
know what's going to break so you have
capabilities like dry run and simulator
as part of policy intelligence that can
look at data over the last 90 days or
longer and can tell you if this change
were to roll out this is what you're
looking at in terms of breakage so
either account for it ahead of time or
revisit how you've defined the control
and then more importantly you don't just
stop there you're constantly analyzing
doing what-if analysis to figure out am
I constantly meeting compliance am I
taking away permissions that people
don't need and that's the analyzer
capability so it's a Continuum of policy
intelligence from recommender simulator
and analyzer and that's available
natively in the IM platform and I'll
show you a demo of that so in terms of
policy and policy intelligence here the
set of announcements that are of
Interest a new control which talks about
organization restrictions uh helps you
to ensure that you can prevent data
exfiltration due to any kind of phishing
or Insider attacks within your
organization in a sense what
organization boundary do you want to set
for your principles and then you can now
achieve greater control on your
organization policies with custom
constraints embedded into your
organization policy and I'll show you a
demo of that in terms of policy
intelligence the ability to do custom
order policy policy simulator and dry
run is now in public preview and then
show off answer how many of you are
already using I am deny
few it's important that you start using
I am deny it's a very very important
control now available in gcp but as you
roll out I am deny you also need to be
able to troubleshoot access issues
because of I am deny so policy
intelligence capability for
troubleshooting access issues for imd9
is now available in public preview
all right one final section and then
demos and then q a so in terms of
emerging scenarios now one thing I
mentioned in the beginning is that
identity is the ultimate threat surface
it is also the ultimate control surface
so one area where directionally a lot of
investment is happening is identity
threat detection and response we've
already started making these
capabilities available in the security
Command Center so if you use even thread
detection in security Command Center you
can get curated rules for identity
related events so let's say you have a
dormant account getting used all of a
sudden or anybody trying to Grant
anomalous access to somebody these kind
of events using user analytics will get
surfaced in security Command Center you
have built-in custom detections and also
playbooks currently for Google Cloud
identity in SCC over time you'll see US
expand this for Workforce identity
Federation and other scenarios in a
sense you can get findings in SCC which
basically tell you you have problems
related to how your identities are
getting used now if you remember when we
spoke about entitlement management we
said that's an admin time activity right
if we are all taking care of those
permissions ahead of time we wouldn't
really have an identity issue but the
reality is no prevention is hundred
percent so you need a runtime catch and
that's what identity threat detection
and response does real time or near real
time can I surface a finding for you
when it looks like something is
malicious with how your identities are
getting used and that's what this
feature allows you to do so I would
encourage you to check this out in
security Command Center premium over
time this is going to enhance more
all right let's quickly look at some
demos so just like we did with the
session we started off by talking about
identity we spoke about policy and
access control and then we spoke about
policy intelligence we'll do the exact
same thing in these three next demos
we're going to start off by looking at
Workforce identity Federation and the
new method of onboarding azure ad or
OCTA as a syncless identity provider in
your system so what you're seeing in
this demo is the new Workforce identity
Federation capability this is going to
start rolling out to your systems in the
next few weeks I can start off by
creating a pool
when I create a pool I need to provide
it a name so I'm going to call my pool
primary Azure ad pool
once the pool gets created it says two
minutes but that's the magic of demos I
can fast forward so in this case the
poll gets created fairly quickly I can
then start configuring my provider so
what you're seeing in the screen is me
configuring my Azure ad tenant to work
in that tool so I provided provide the
issuer URL the assertion claims the
secret I can then specify how do the how
does the attribute schema map between my
source IDP and Google so in this case
I'm basically asserting how do the
subject and how do the groups translate
with each other I click continue and
submit and what that's going to do is
create my pool it's going to create my
provider I'll execute a few commands on
the Azure 80 side and from that point on
I'll be able to use Azure ad in a
syncless manner to access Google cloud
services it is actually as simple as
that so this is the new Workforce
identity Federation configuration UI and
it's going to start rolling out to you
to your deployments in the next few
weeks and it's going to show up under I
am right under workload identity
Federation so that's how you onboard
your third party identity provider
without having to synchronize it
the next demo that I have on the screen
is let's say you have a resource Centric
policy that takes care of certain
behavior that the resources shouldn't
follow so for example in GCS Google
Cloud Storage you have a canned policy
or an inbuilt policy which enforces
Public Access prevention that means that
these buckets cannot be publicly
accessed and if this policy is enabled
at a project level it applies to all
buckets in that project now you may have
scenarios where you do want a few
buckets to have public access and the
only way that you achieve that right now
is you actually move those buckets to a
different project and you don't apply
the policy on the other project and
that's how you achieve the separation
between and that's not really you know
useful it's actually pretty cumbersome
to have to create a different project
just to apply a policy a different way
so in this demo what you'll see is I
have the canned enforced Public Access
prevention policy that's available in
every account
I can now add a custom constraint or
custom policy within the org policy
itself what this one says is that if I
have a resource tag as allow Public
Access yes this could be whatever tag
you want to use in my case I said if I
ever have a resource which says allow
Public Access yes override the policy so
here I have two buckets confidential
images and public images currently
notice tags are empty for both of them
I try to load the public access and it
won't
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
go back to the buckets View and I'm
going to add that tag to the public
access bucket and this is using the new
secure tax capability that's available
in Im so I'm going to specify allow
Public Access yes I click save it goes
through in a few seconds the Dax should
start showing up on that screen let's go
load that bucket again and hopefully
this time the image will load
there you have it so this allows you to
configure your organization policies
with custom constraints and more
importantly use capabilities like
resource tags which are echoed in a very
robust manner to really have the
positive that you need and not have to
create multiple projects just to have
different policies apply against your
against your bucket so this is also
available now so this is customizing
policies with resource tags and then
finally we spoke about policy
intelligence and the importance of I am
deny so I am deny if it's applicable
within your organization or if a
principal has an IM deny policy
configured against them and if they
don't see the right access typically
they're like usually confused why am I
not seeing this access so now you can
use the policy intelligence
troubleshooter to really figure out why
a principle is not getting the access
that they think that they should have so
back in our GCS storage view you'll see
my create option for creating a new
bucket is currently grayed out so I'm
not able to create a bucket if I I hover
over it it tells me that maybe you have
an I am deny that's blocking you go talk
to your administrator and have them
figure out why you don't have access so
with segregation of Duties in play you
would create a ticket for your
administrator previously your
administrator would look at a bunch of
policies and try to troubleshoot it now
what they can do is they can go run a
report for your principle and for the
permission that you expect to see within
a matter of a few seconds the report
comes back and says your principal was
right in that they did have allowed for
them but we wrote a deny policy on top
of it which explicitly said in this case
it says for me you're not allowed to
create a bucket and that's why deny
trumps allow and the access is not going
through but it's just the ability to
troubleshoot that access issue you can
imagine I am deny is an important
control but when you roll out a control
along with it comes Toil and more work
for people but if you have capabilities
like these you can roll allow the
control in a risk-free manner but then
also have ability to support your
principles when they run into access
issues and give them the right
information on what's really happening
this capability is also now in public
preview available in policy intelligence
right under IM
all right with that I am through with
the planned content well within time we
have nine minutes for Q a
um I before we get to q a I'm gonna
encourage you to take a screenshot or
take a photograph of this particular
slide two sessions that I strongly
recommend later today security 201 which
is about defining security Baseline so
my team is going to walk you through
policy based Investments a targeted
policy section from the session and
they'll have snap and box on stage with
them and then security 300 which is
going to go deeper into the identity
area and the team's gonna have Goldman
Sachs with them on stage so all of the
stuff that I gave you the theory the
customers are going to tell you how they
actually implement it and there might be
some great learnings for all of us as a
community
[Music]
foreign